dans la banlieue de tours une grosse
concession auto moon d'un côté de
vendeurs ce matin-là ils n'ont pas l'air
franchement débordés en revanche de
l'autre côté il y en a une qui n'a pas
le temps de souffler
fabienne ans celle déjà son cinquième
rendez-vous de la matinée la vendeuse
vivre d'abord un 4/4 à ce commerçant
pour 65000 euros puis un break à 34
milles euros à ce jeune homme venu
acheter avec son père elle ne s'arrête
jamais le coffre donc avec des langues
qui vont se battre pas moyen de mettre
un coeur de tour de clef s'il vous plaît
cette fois ci c'est un coupé à 40000
euros que s'offrent ce retraité fabienne
david pons 31 ans
les clients se l'arrachent la première
fois qu'une femme - de voiture oui oui
[Musique]
c'est pas désagréable
pendant que fabienne vend des voitures
ses collègues masculins en sont réduits
à attendre les clients
et quand on appelle au standard c'est
toujours pour elle de quoi les rendre
jaloux
les chiffres de fabienne se parlent
d'eux mêmes ils sont impressionnants
c'est une vendeuse performante qu'il
accroche le client
une très très bonne bande aux jusque là
l'image des femmes dans le milieu de
l'automobile c'était sa jolie fille qui
au mondial de paris aux comme des
plantes vertes
à côté des voitures mais une petite
révolution est en marche
tous les constructeurs recherchent
maintenant des vendeuses de choc
une étude interne d'un fabricant
français dont la presse s'est fait
l'écho révèle que ces vendeuses vend
deux fois plus de voitures que leurs
collègues masculins en moyenne 300
véhicules vendus chaque année contre 150
pourquoi et comment les femmes s'y
prend-elle dans cet univers réputé très
macho pour appâter les clients dans sa
concession
fabienne affairés un bon client pantalon
il y a deux ans ce pdg lui avait déjà
acheté une voiture à 35000 euros
ce jour là monsieur a choisi une grosse
berline deux fois plus cher à 75000
euros
il s'est déjà fait son opinion fabienne
ne parle pas beaucoup
elle appuie juste sur les petits détails
de l'été tissier du confort assez pour
que je m'en sert énormément monsieur
c'est quand même hyper sympa l'été avant
tout à fait et puis avec l'intérieur
cuir beige c'est vrai que c'est sa porte
aussi un peu de lumière s'est trouvée
l'arrière avec les petits rideaux
pare-soleil
donc là on est sur l or est sûre du 3
litres à toute façon la croix litres un
gros moteur visiblement monsieur semble
déjà convaincu fabienne ne soulèvera
même pas le capot la vendeuse va
maintenant concentrer tous ses efforts
sur le financement car elle joue une
bonne partie de sa commission sur le
crédit vous l'aviez financer le lot 6
auprès de votre banque
une fois d'ailleurs le bureau
changement d'ambiance cette fois c'est
elle qui reprend la main
la chaussure du crédit classique donc là
creux dit voilà crédit classique 72 400
sur 60 mois parce qu'on ne peut pas
aller au delà apport 0 donc sans apport
est là donc 60 mensualités à 1758 88,0
là au bout des cinq ans soul 2 0 en 10
minutes s'est vu avec fabienne pas de
négociation à couteaux tirés
question de galanterie même pour de très
grosses sommes
le client n'insiste pas c'est certes un
classement des féminins quelquefois je
joue un tout petit peu son rôle j'ai un
peu plus de mal au niveau de la
négociation à être aussi incisif coup
d'être que s'ils étaient calmes
je vais vous dire que je me laisse faire
non plus hein c'est pas ça
ça c'est possible les gens sont très
respectueux il était un peu plus de
retenue
je pense oui c'est un atout parce qu'il
se se permettrait peut-être parmi des
réflexions ou des remarques celle d'une
femme
le problème peut plus facilement ses
deux collègues n'ont pas vendu grand
chose fabienne elle a réalisé 150 mille
euros de chiffre d'affaires
franck le directeur a une manière bien à
lui de présenter cette concurrence
interne entre la vendeuse de choc et ses
deux homologues masculins en caricature
oui je la présente comme un requin avec
deux petits peu feront jouer ses deux
collègues c'est pas très flatteur pour
eux mais c'est vrai que par contre
l'image de requins
plus à vis de fabienne je pense lui va
bien parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
prédateur
une belle réussite pour cette ancienne
hôtesse d'accueil de concession qui
gagnait il y a encore dix ans le smic
car depuis son salaire s'est envolé
fabienne touche un salaire fixe de 1200
euros brut
à cela il faut ajouter les commissions
sur les ventes de voitures et les
crédits en moyenne pour chaque véhicule
vendu
cela représente 400 euros de bonus du
coup ses revenus atteignent des sommets
8000 euros par mois de quoi laisser
songeur même son patron louis
ils ont vertement c'est un des plus gros
salaires
nous sommes pour le groupe toujours à la
recherche de miss voilà on a dur des
femmes comme fabienne toutes les grandes
marques en voudrait
[Musique]
les constructeurs l'ont bien compris les
vendeuses rapporte deux fois plus que
les vendeurs seulement le réseau
commercial de toutes ces grandes marques
est composé à 95% de petits patrons
indépendants libres de leur recrutement
et certains ont encore un raisonnement
un peu sexiste
nous en avons fait l'expérience oui
bonjour monsieur je m'appelle marié je
vous appelle au sujet de votre poste de
vendeur en fait par téléphone nous avons
répondu à des offres d'emploi passé par
ses concessionnaires à la recherche de
vendeurs et voici le discours plutôt
surprenant qui nous ont tenus
c'est très particulier comme respectable
avec elle j'ai 21 ans
que voulez vous dire mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas sur vingt petites annonces
aucune réponse positive et les trois
quart des concessionnaires exclu
carrément toute candidature féminine
alors pour devenir vendeuse de voiture
mieux vaut être particulièrement motivé
dans la région de lyon véronique 24 ans
est passionné d'automobile après un an
de stage dans une concession
elle est à la recherche d'un emploi dans
le secteur un responsable vais au
commerce un conseiller clientèle bon ça
c'est pour une location donc c'est un
peu différent mais sinon c'est vrai que
c'est essentiellement masculin véronique
a étudié dans une école de vente
automobile de sa région elle était la
seule femme de sa promotion elle est
sortie major devant tous les garçons
mais pourtant elle n'a rien trouvé en un
mois de recherche
[Musique]
ce matin elle a finalement réussi à
décrocher un entretien d'embauché dans
cette succursale qui appartient en
direct à une grande marque
toute la question c'est de savoir
comment se vendre dans un univers
masculin où les femmes n'ont pas la cote
véronique a décidé d'employer les grands
moyens bonjour wernick dernier cheval
pour l'entretien avec monsieur chris
dyer merci donc là normalement c'est un
poste pour l'occasion ils arrivent
jusque là ce garage n'emploie que des
hommes neufs messieurs dirigé par bruno
cuisine
merci mais le directeur a bien reçu des
consignes de la maison mère qui souhaite
féminiser les effectifs mais encore
faut-il que véronique puisse démontrer
qu'elle est à la hauteur des autres
vendeurs qui travaille pour la
concession
ben ouais c'est très simple en fait je
veux faire ce métier tout simplement
parce que c'était c'est toujours été une
passion pour moi depuis que je suis
toute petite c'est toujours embêté mes
parents pour ça j'ai toujours voulu
arriver à mon but
alors bon c'est parce que j'adore les
voitures le directeur s'intéresse au
stage d'un an qu'elle a effectués chez
un concessionnaire
puis il décide de l'interrompre pour
mettre les pieds dans le plat
vous avez conscience que le milieu
automobile au milieu masculin
oui ça c'est tout à fait ben j'en ai
pris conscience dès le début dès que
j'ai su dès que vous de l'année passée
dans cette concession ça s'est bien
passé ou d'intégration alors ça s'est
bien passé sauf que j'ai eu quand même
pas mal de bâtons dans les roues 1 ce
qui est normal en tant que fille en tant
que débutante entendu filles beaucoup en
tant que fille ben parce que on doit
faire beaucoup plus
enfin davantage de d'amener beaucoup
plus d'eux propose par rapport voilà par
rapport au milieu automobile
et puis par rapport à l'essentiel mandé
un milieu masculin donc tout simplement
véronique a les dents longues
le directeur voit tout de suite le parti
qu'il peut en tirer pour son équipe de
vente anne on n'aime pas se faire
doubler par ça pousse les ventes vers le
haut et puis ça donne un peu de
fraîcheur sur une analyse est que vous
booste y ait une équipe
je veux vous comprenez ça va très fait
en privé oui moi je pense oui parce que
par rapport aux siens c'est une fille
donc à manger dans notre assiette donc
il faut on va falloir va falloir se
défendre et moi je vais je vais être là
pour les booster parce que j'ai bien
l'intention de leur piquer leurs leur
dessert du mois
des clients tout simplement été des
clients le plus possible enfin pas leur
piquer mais voilà pas les mêmes
disons que j'ai pas leur piquer ce qui
leurs clients qui sont appropriées quand
même les petits passent si les voyais
pas moi je les verrai voilà c'est tout
séduit par sa détermination le
responsable du magasin lui donne sa
chance
véronique sera sa toute première
vendeuse il a compris tout l'intérêt de
faire débarquer une femme au beau milieu
de ces neuf vendeurs et revendeurs qui
les envoie en disant c'est probablement
plus que moi pourquoi véronique sera
embauchée en cdi à un salaire fixe de
800 euros brut par mois
mais avec les commissions elle devrait
très vite toucher le salaire moyen d'une
vendeuse de voitures 2500 euros par mois
au revoir la rémunération est très
attractive quand on connaît les ficelles
du métier
[Musique]
seulement la vente ça ne s'improvise pas
alors quels obstacles les débutants ne
doivent-elles surmonter dans cet univers
encore très masculin
caroline crennel 29 ans était hôtesse de
l'air
après quelques mois de chômage et un
petit boulot dans le prêt-à-porter
elle a entendu parler d'un bon plan qui
devrait rapporter le double de ce
qu'elle gagne les assedic lui paye et
une formation pour devenir vendeuse de
voitures 20 jours d'école et dix jours
de travaux pratiques par mois pour elle
pas de concessions rutilante mais un
garage de la banlieue de montpellier
spécialisé dans la voiture d'occasion et
elle doit un peu tout faire la
décoration le parking et même
l'affichage
je regarde que les pancartes soit bien
bien noter que tous les prix hippique et
bien tout pour que ce soit clair pas
pour le client en fait que les plantes
soient bien mises que voilà que ce soit
parfait avant de commencer avant de
faire l'ouverture c'est pas important
mais c'est c'est le petit plus ça fait
joli ça fait sympa ça fait plus ça fait
une touche féminine
ça me correspond j'ai essayé comme celle
univers où je travaille
j'essayais que ça me reflète le plus
possible voilà caroline fait de son
mieux pour apprendre mais c'est loin
d'être gagné
exemple avec la petite voiture que
viennent de repérer ses clients caroline
s'apprête à entrer en scène
il va falloir faire avec le trac
[Musique]
alalala constater les larmes déclenchée
par accident ça commence plutôt mal et
caroline croyez avoir réglé le problème
du long métrage 91 mille kilomètres
[Applaudissements]
fonctionne c'est super
ce client n'est pas au bout de ses
surprises il doit se débrouiller tout
seul pour inspecter l'intérieur de la
voiture car la vendeuse est déjà parti à
l'avant du véhicule
elle a décidé de lui montrer le moteur
mais là encore problème elle n'arrive
pas à se dépatouiller avec le capot
c'est un mauvais point une bonne
vendeuse n'a pas besoin de s'aventurer
sur le terrain de la mécanique
caroline perd tous ses moyens
sous le regard interloqué des clients
elle est même dépassée par leurs
questions
je sais pas si ça a été fait
91e kilomètres ça m'étonnerait qu'elle
ait été fait ça m'étonnerait maintenant
je vais me
je me renseignerai
ouais les réponses pour le moins
approximative mais il lui reste une
dernière chance
la vendeuse en formation espère se
rattraper au moment où le client prend
le volant pour faire un petit tour
d'essai alors à la baisse
l'acteur automatique au bout de quelques
mètres
le patron du garage leur fait signe de
s'arrêter immédiatement il y a un souci
[Rires]
quand on vend des voitures d'occasion il
y a une règle d'or ne jamais inquiété le
client mais caroline va faire une gaffe
en soulevant elle même la question de la
fiabilité du véhicule et vous savez que
de toute façon si vous avez un problème
rapidement le vous revenez y a pas de
soucis mécaniques sauveur sur les trois
que ce soit quand on est passé à travers
malheureusement vous pouvez revenir
aucun problème
caroline l'avouer elle même la voiture
risque de tomber en panne
la vente de 9000 euros est raté
pour le patron de ce petit garage qui a
accepté de prendre une femme en
formation sa stagiaire n'est pas encore
au point
partir on ne peut pas lui demander
américains débutent
je pense qu'il faut lui laisser
de cannes pour l'informer et tout ça
c'est sûr que bon il ya quelques petites
erreurs comme tout à l'heure je sais pas
si vous avez vu on va essayer une
voiture avec un panneau bon pour moi
c'est une erreur c'est une erreur parce
que si le panneau samoa on peut causer
un accident c'est un tas de trucs qu'il
faut voir il faut faut vraiment être un
être concentré et surtout ne pas
raconter de bêtises parce que tôt ou
tard ça vous retombe dessus dans la
vente
caroline a encore du chemin à faire pour
maîtriser toutes les ficelles du métier
mais des vendeuses de voitures les
constructeurs y croit dur comme fer
chez le premier fabricant français les
femmes ne représentent encore que 10 %
des effectifs
mais ce chiffre devrait doubler dans les
prochaines années
[Musique]